alors alain bashung bonsoir pourvoir
ensuite c'est un disque qui l'appelle
novices ouais les exégètes se sont mis
au travail alors il ya novices et
n'obéissent ait eu comme c'est écrit sur
la pochette est aussi novice n os bsnes
uno vice en anglais tu penses quoi de ce
genre de cuire env en tout ce que tout
ce que bagnon effet sur toi dans dans
libération c'est une bonne question est
ce que tu comprends moi je ne cherche
pas à comprendre les fictions des
pleines pages sur toi mais c'est
toujours un peu compliqué il raconte une
aventure et le délire et c'est une façon
de permettre quelque chose tu peux en
parler avec le médecin
en décortiquant musicalement en vidant
tel musicien ce pas mal ou le hic c'est
super ça c'est un aspect mais me rendre
légendaire je trouve c'est un sourire en
s'allégeant des personnes ya toi yam ans
et liam y aura des gains de nous et du
tronc vous êtes c'est les gens c'est
bien
bah oui je suis surtout content que rick
et des personnes
qu'ils comprennent elle a émis tout ce
que je dis qu il ya quand même deux
tendances dans ce que tu fais yalla
yalla ligne dure
ces play blessures c'est technopole un
peu comme ça c'est ce que tu as appelé
la cacophonie rigoureuse où les erreurs
délibéré ah ça c'est le macho
un peu artiste me dire que un peu hard
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui quand on
écoute play blessures
c'est beaucoup plus classique ou plus
facile que contre les goûters la
première fois les pieds un peu le côté
top 53 ya pizza et a passé le rio grande
et qui était comme ça est bourré de
calembours un qui a été meilleur disque
de rock de l'année
mais entre ces entre ces deux lignes
comme ça entre la la ligne dure et la
ligne pizza disons tout sens où là bas
depuis
tu connaissais le disque avant pizza il
y avait roulé truths way et c'était
s'était pas vraiment une forme de tore
boyau à part quand même c'était un peu
ténébreux mais je crois que j'ai ça m'a
aidé à prendre du recul sur moi enfin tu
vois je tous ces mecs qui gamberge trop
comme ça que j'en fais partie je me pose
trop de questions et qui finalement
c'est bien aussi tu vas mais ça me
permet de s'ouvrir temps en temps c'est
cher indices comme ça produire
normalement ça doit pas être cher je
trouve que le dernier a coûté trop cher
l'avivo et combien lannoy lys je sais
pas peut-être 80 75 bruit huawei un truc
comme ça mais il est si je cours je
trouve ça scandaleux
l'enfant il faut en vendre combien pour
rembourser je sais pas peut-être 80 800
milliards comme ça oui
ce envisageable
ah oui bah je je vois en correctement
des algues ont donc fait pas chier de
compte et était comptable quand tu étais
petit noir j'ai failli être concédées
comment alors machine campagne bas
c'était un mec qui était sur des rails
parfait pour lui tu âgées
j'ai fait un stage chez péchiney une
fois pour 10 dons il fallait faire il
fallait faire un dossier dont pour
passer l'examen
ce rendu compte à quel point c'était
parfait pour moi non et j'ai eu un refus
du chiffre total est et je n'aurais
peut-être pas dû avant un refus
systématique du 6e catégorie celui ci
voulait pas rendre le métier de ton père
boulanger
non j'ai taquiner un peu quand j'ai des
petits parce que j'ai aidé un peu je
vivrai d
des gâteaux pour les mariages d immense
gâteau vie y est trois fois plus grand
que moi j'avais des pourboires et puis
partez pas voulu rester dans la farine
non le pétrin tu sais tu sortie ouais et
pourrait-elle en alsace ben mes parents
de pas mal de difficultés à hydra
parisot une petite pièce puis bon je
suis parti chez la grand-mère de service
que sa porte
un petit village bon c'est pas facile
d'être de nulle part des pb bendahmane
c'est sacré des trois familiaux un peu
quand l excuse je te pique je t'en prie
merci cap et a fait pas mal de galères
quand même c'est vrai que tu as été
producteur de dick rivers oui je fais ça
recommence
c'est ce qu'avait abandonné tu te dis
d'être sur le devant de la scène
mais le climat s'y prêtait pas seul le
seul large qui avait fait des trucs
faille avec quelques arrivées dutronc
non c'est bon
mais c'était une période
très variétés tuheiava mort n'est pas
forcément dans les méchants
c'est pas le moment le plus dur à cette
époque c'est que tu voudrais plus jamais
revivre
je vivais avec une femme
c'était pâques aussi je crois que c'est
ce qu'elle pensait qu'au fric et et moi
je moi je pouvais gagner de l'argent à
travers une passion et je pouvais pas me
dire maintenant à cause de l'argent et
la passion du rap et j'avais ça en tête
je pouvais pas exister autrement alors
si tu sais pas si c'est très égoïste ou
quoi sam et artistes j'étais comme ça tu
vois je j'essaie de faire plein de jobs
est rien
rien ne décollait aux moyens ne
réussissais tueur alors je trafic est un
peu à gauche à droite tu fais une
comédie musicale je faisais en faisait
des cover l'époque de
d'autres artistes vu que quand ils
avaient des complices et des plus grands
succès de johnny hallyday par exemple
mais avec sa photo est chanté par billy
cheminots du var étaient tous accusés ap
mais moi je faisais les voir au que
notre charge la vie de leurs écharpes je
me parfois s'attendent huit ans tandis
qu'elle est géniale idée de la new wave
c'est un peu ce un peu théorique bon
pour moi mais je sais peut-être pas
complètement non mais c'est pas
totalement faux certainement masque
mouiller
il était
à commencer par du rock quand même il
n'a pas baigné forcément dans la musique
classique mais à ce moment là il ya des
moments télé j arriverai jamais j'avais
je n'avais rien à [ __ ] de me réveiller
le matin puis un jour ça va tellement
mal que je me suis dit c'est là que tu
découvres que finalement tu peux pas
descendre plus bas et tu veux être
augmentés quoi tu as eu et on a eu assez
classique mais c'est vrai c'est pas des
conneries
maintenant tu tape un peu le look
famille mais bien le dire
le style tu viens atterrés nous parler
de ton petit arthur qui vais bientôt
aussi célèbre que le petit lui oui mais
je pars faire au baby là dessus comme ça
c'est pas gênant pour les fans des
témoins disent trahis je crois pas parce
que je j'ai vécu vraiment cette période
là c'est pas comme si je vous racontais
des histoires de science fiction tu vas
et je souhaite à personne de vivre saad
dans cet état je crois qu'il faut y
arriver
d'une autre manière on peut y arriver
d'une autre manière ce n'est pas
forcément facile
il ya un moment 82 tu disais
face à croix le moment où tu t'es
séparer de bergman pendant un moment et
u10 et j'étais à deux doigts de la mort
ça veut dire quoi ce nom il fallait que
j'arrive pour trouver en suisse comme
une star comme une star qui vous a fait
la clinique en suisse la clinique en
suisse que parfaitement règlements
clairs et maintenant tu vois plus que du
café kwaï de l'eau huawei aubenas c'est
pareil à un moment où tu sais que tu as
fait ton du problème
ouais j'ai goûté un bac pas mal de truc
c'était bien mal aux yeux bon le médecin
il te dira un jour écoute tu t'arrêtes
tu craches de pied voilà bon tu peux
faire comme gainsbourg
il gère beaucoup moi et j'avais beaucoup
donc
donc j'imagine qu'ils marchent pas le
disque la novice tu te diras quoiqu'il
ait pas bon c'est les gens qui sont pas
bons ce qui est important c'est que je
vois d'accord avec cet album j'ai bien
fait d'accord non j'ai pas totalement
blague mais ce qui me paraît très
important c'est d'être d'abord d'accord
avec cet album et ensuite on verra